well if you know me you know I spend a
lot of time in front of this wall
bouncing around looking at the economic
data looking at the grass getting quite
excited by them but I'm afraid the grass
that we have here for a over nineteen
are deeply depressing some of the most
depressing I've ever seen and let me
explain why the news is ultimately quite
bad and you might not have got that from
looking at the covert nineteen cases we
had this from public health England
today it was in the press conference and
it looked like there was something of a
plateauing but the key thing is cases
don't necessarily give you the best
indication of what's going on underneath
the surface given that we are only
testing so many people here in the UK
you get a better sense of where the UK
stands in comparison with other
countries by looking at the number of
people dying from cope of nineteen and
that picture well looking at this chart
which just shows you the sheer
cumulative number of deaths in various
different countries around the world you
might know I've got a sense that the UK
has much of a problem it's here quite
low down compared with Spain and Italy
but what we need to do is not look at
absolute numbers which this is doing but
at growth rates something called a
logarithmic shot so we'll take exactly
that data change the axis so we're
looking at growth rates rather than the
absolute numbers and look it's a very
different story indeed actually the UK
on this kind of line here and I want to
just show you the UK and Italy just to
give you a sense of what we're talking
about here because things have evolved a
bit over the course of the last few days
so initially the first eight days and
we're starting here after the hundreds
hundreds death the first eight days
after that it took Italy eight days to
get to a thousand deaths so from a
hundred to a thousand took Italy eight
days of 33% every day daily increase in
death in the UK for those first eight
days actually the growth was lower the
growth rate in the number of deaths was
lower and so by eight days the UK was
only up to 578 so a good news story the
UK's line was flatter everyone's talking
about flattening those curves the UK's
line was indeed flatter then the Italian
line started to flatten so over the next
six days in Italy there were twenty
percent daily increases in deaths but
look at what happens at the UK line
slightly steeper in fact 27 percent
growth increase and that's where we are
now so we've got two thousand three
hundred and fifty two cumulative deaths
in UK hospitals that's just in hospitals
some you know question marks over
whether the number should be bigger than
that and you can see these lines have
started to converge and that's the
worrying thing is the UK DEF lines are
basically converging on Italy and the
worry is so there's actually right now
the worry is if the UK carries on
growing as it is at the moment 27%
growth in the number of people dying
then you are up to 10,000 deaths
basically within a week now that's a
depressing number it suggests the UK
might well be heading to get above the
Italian line that's why people are
talking about flattening these lines and
behind every one of these statistics is
a family many friends who have lost a
loved one it is very depressing stuff
but unfortunately that is what the data
is suggesting the hope for number 10 is
that they can flatten those lines and
ensure that the UK number of deaths get
down but at the moment the omens don't
look particularly promising